we got to about 25 feet and I thought
well that's actually really high now and
then you just keep going are you afraid
of heights these 20 actors made the
power of flight look effortless on the
big screen but we all know that there
had to be more going on behind the
scenes number one flying isn't nearly as
fun as it seems as Harry Potter Daniel
Radcliffe has been both suspended from
wires and sat on rigs before a blue
screen he has since admitted that he
found the broomstick rigs to be
especially uncomfortable once explaining
in an interview with Digital Spy that
flying does hurt quite a lot and that
it's not something he would rush back to
do number two she was literally flying
up that hill when Sadie sink first saw
the harness she was to wear for Max's
levitation scene in season 4 of stranger
things she couldn't help but remark I
feel like this is the most elaborate
form of harness scene that I've ever
done she was then gradually lifted into
the air on wires leveraged by the pull
of a rope resulting in an effect that
sink herself described as so scary upon
watching it back number three not
everyone on set for Harry Potter hated
flying Tom Felton's Memoir fondly
recalled his time spent on the
broomstick rigs to ensure the actors had
their eye lines correct a crew member
would extend a tennis ball on a pole for
them to watch and so the actors would
tape beloved pictures to these tennis
balls Felton claimed that Daniel
Radcliffe taped up a picture of his
celebrity crush Cameron Diaz whereas he
had chosen an even more beautiful carp
number 4. Star-Lord mayfly using his
jetpack but on set it's mostly performed
using wires Chris Pratt has come to be
so comfortable in the harness in fact
that he's even let his nine-year-old son
fly around on wires when he came to
visit him on set while filming 2021's
the tomorrow War number five she faced
her fears and came out stronger for it
Emily Blunt is terrified of heights but
that didn't stop her from being attached
to wires and lifted 45 feet in the air
with a crane for her role as Mary
Poppins although the only thing on her
mind was whether I thought I was going
to die she did it anyway and got
rewarded with a high five from
lin-manuel Miranda Upon returning no
number six Practically Perfect is far
from the way we describe this stunt
Julie Andrews performed her flying scene
for Mary Poppins on the final day of
filming in case of an accident which may
have set the wrong tone while being
lowered to the ground on wires she felt
herself slip about six inches Andrews
called up to request a soft landing at
which point she plummeted straight down
fortunately the balancing weight she had
been placed on kept her safe leaving her
shaken but alive number seven Gal Gadot
would do anything for her friends her
work as Wonder Woman had her both hooked
up to rig work and strapped into
harnesses and she's even performed an
aerial stunt on wires above the U.S
Capitol yet Gadot would later come to
regret the stunt work she did for Wonder
Woman 1984 when she developed spinal
injuries after filming admitting that
she'd had a difficult time saying no to
her close friend and director Patty
Jenkins number eight it's your friend
neighborhood Spider-Man to swing Labs
like Spidey Tom Holland was attached to
a wire rig suspended from a crane which
would then drop him and swing in an arc
with only cardboard boxes placed beneath
him for safety Holland's background as
an acrobat and gymnast allows him to
perform many of his own stunts although
CGI comes in handy for anything that's
too dangerous number nine you can never
be too comfortable as an actor One
Division went fairly old school with
their use of wires to make Vision appear
to fly in the beginning of the
miniseries only using heavy cranes in
the later episodes far from being
nervous Paul betney's previous
experience with harnesses in Avengers
Age of Ultron meant that he was much
more worried about performing in front
of a live audience for the first time
number 10 do you believe in fairies
having performed her own stunts in
previous films Angelina showed no fear
when it came time to be strapped into a
harness and suspended in the air from a
crane for Maleficent tuning Forks were
also used in order to capture more
three-dimensional aerial movements while
her wings were added afterwards using
CGI number 11. Elizabeth Olsen is one
actress who knows her way around an
aerial stunt as the Scarlet Witch she's
been made to appear Airborne using
nearly every trick imaginable she's
shown off bumps and bruises on social
media along with captions like Scarlet
Witch took flight yesterday and got a
bruise and yet she never seems to take
these injuries too seriously and even
enjoys joking around in the tuning Forks
number 12. sometimes all you need is a
good friend Catherine Hahn took flight
AS Agatha Harkness through the use of
wires while off-screen fans kept her
hair blowing Han has admitted that she
was grateful to have Elizabeth Olsen on
set with her claiming that she was my
intro into this Marvel family and she
very generously walked me through blasts
and wires and stuns and finding truth on
an ax on a green screen number 13 Sarah
Jessica Parker was a natural witch in
fact while filming for Hocus Pocus she
loved flying in the harness so much that
she would sit in it for hours between
takes or while the crew was taking their
lunch she would keep a rolled up
newspaper tucked in the back of her
corset to read midair perfectly fine no
I was happy I was better than fine
number 14 there's more than one way to
fly for the super powered flight of
Captain Marvel Brie Larson was both
strapped into harnesses and hooked up to
rig work photos from said of her wearing
a big smile while in the harness seems
to suggest that she had a lot of fun
doing it funnily enough she enjoyed
flying in a plane a lot less as filming
her piloting scenes actually made her
sick on set number 15. when you're the
master of the Mystic Arts you need to
know how to fly Benedict Cumberbatch
already had plenty of experience with
harnesses before he'd even joined the
MCU as Steven strange a photo set of him
on the set of Sherlock shows Cumberbatch
hanging from a harness off the side of a
building comfortably enough to take off
his jacket and smile in Doctor Strange
tuning Forks are also used for more
three-dimensional aerial movement number
16 Henry Cavill takes his stunt work
seriously the flight for Man of Steel
was accomplished in a number of ways
from wire rigging to gimbal rigs CGI
helped enhance some of the more
cinematic flight scenes but seeing as
Henry Cavill believes in doing as many
of his own stunts as possible it comes
as no surprise that he was willing to
strap himself into a harness whenever he
could number 17 filming for television
in the 1970s sure was a different scene
for Wonder Woman Linda Carter once
dangled mid-air from a helicopter
without the use of wires wrist guards or
safety nets Carter's stunt double was
supposed to step in for her but she
decided to do it herself when it was
discovered that the stunt double didn't
look enough like her Carter got in
trouble with the network afterwards for
the unnecessary risk but otherwise
walked away unscathed number 18 you
could not pay us enough to try this
stunt for his role as Hancock Will Smith
was not only suspended 200 feet above
the city landscape on wires but the
crane would actually proceed to propel
him at 50 miles per hour Believe It or
Not Smith was complete completely cool
with the idea stating that the computer
effects look great but it's more fun to
get your hands dirty number 19 flying
isn't quite as easy as Faith trust and
pixie dust the 2003 movie Peter Pan used
both wires for the more intensive flying
stunts as well as tuning forks for more
Dynamic aerial shots Jeremy Sumpter said
the experience was amazing but
emphasized how much work it involved
claiming that he had to exercise for two
hours a day six days a week in order to
perform the stunts number 20 it helps to
have some experience the 1978 Superman
film pioneered the use of the zoptic
front projection system a camera effect
that would allow Christopher Reeve to
appear as though he were flying even if
he were lying completely flat using his
prior experience as a trained pilot
Reeves simply imagined that he were in
Flight while being suspended from the
wires so that he would actually move his
arms as though he were sitting in a
plane although these actors were asked
to perform superhuman Feats for the sake
of of a role they still manage to make
it look easy which flying scenes were
you most impressed by